en europe les pays bas transfèrent leurs
premiers patients vers des hôpitaux en
allemagne en cause des systèmes
hospitaliers néerlandais déjà en
surcharge l'allemagne ainsi que le
danemark sont par ailleurs deux
destinations que les états unis
déconseillent à leurs ressortissants
le point sur la situation outre rhin
avec peter oliver à berlin pour rt
internationale
un débat crucial a lieu en ce moment en
allemagne le pays doit-il suivre
l'exemple de l'autriche et rendre la
vaccination obligatoire cette mesure
entre en vigueur en autriche à partir du
1er février de l'année prochaine le
débat en allemagne porte surtout sur la
question de savoir si cette mesure est
légitime dans le cadre de la
constitution en vigueur d'autres mesures
ont déjà été prises dans certaines
régions allemandes notamment le
couvre-feu interdisant de sortir de chez
soi après 22 heures après l'état de
bavière l'état de saxe et d'autres
villes allemandes la ville de stuttgart
est la dernière à annuler des marchés de
noël pendant les fêtes hivernales angela
merkel a caractérisé cette nouvelle
vague de kobe 19 de pire que tout ce
qu'on a connu le ministre de la santé
jens panne lui a exposé sa vision des
choses et il est plutôt pessimiste
probablement à la fin de l'hiver comme
on le dit parfois avec cynisme chacun ou
presque en allemagne sera vacciné guéri
ou mort mais c'est vrai en raison de la
propagation du variant delta très très
contagieux c'est fort probable
pendant ce temps l'autriche vie le
deuxième jour du nouveau confinement au
niveau national il durera au moins dix
jours et pourra être prolongée jusqu'au
13 décembre
les gens là bas en autriche est ici en
allemagne expriment leur préoccupation
concernant les mesures prises par le
gouvernement en se demandant si elle
était bonne
je ne crois pas du tout que le
confinement s'achèvera dans trois
semaines même pour nous qui avons déjà
été vaccinées c'est comme ça
c'est trop tard trop tard surtout la
vaccination obligatoire cette mesure
aurait dû être prise plus tôt mais pas
en février
compte apporter ces derniers mois on a
vu des vaccinations on a fait des tests
respecter la distanciation porter des
masques mais le nombre de cas qu vide
augmente malgré tout je ne pense pas que
ce soit bien d'abord ils ont dit que
tout allait s'ouvrir puis ils ont tous
construits finalement on nous dit qu'il
faudrait tous fermés et qu'on ne
pourrait rien ouvrir
en slovaquie et en république tchèque le
nombre de cas de covin ne cesse pas non
plus d'augmenter alors dans ces deux
pays des restrictions supplémentaires
ont été mises en place à partir de lundi
interdisant aux personnes non vaccinées
l'accès aux hôtels au bar au salon de
coiffure et à presque toutes les
réunions publiques car ils ont peur de
manquer de lits en soins intensifs en
raison du nombre important de personnes
touchées par le colis de 19